This video is brought to you by
Squarespace websites and online stores to
marketing tools and analytics.
Squarespace is the only one platform to
build a beautiful online presence and
run your business head to squarespace.com
for a free trial and when you're ready
to launch,
go to squarespace.com forward slash player
graphics and save 10% off your first
purchase of a website or domain.
Ferdinand's Magellan was one of the
leading explorers of the age of discovery,
often being cited as the first
man to circumnavigate the globe.
He actually fell just short of that
milestone being hacked to death by the
natives on the Mariana's islands.
Yet his vision and tenacity,
despite tremendous odds,
opens up the westward route
to Asia and established.
His legacy is one of history's great
adventurers. In today's biographics,
we uncover the life and the tragic
death of Ferdinand Magellan.
Fascinans Magellan was born around
1480 in the north of Portugal.
His family were part
Portuguese aristocracy.
His father read Omega Hayes was an
official in the city of [inaudible] wild,
the family of his mother
ILDs in a mosquito.
We're well connected to
the Portuguese royal court.
Both parents though they died when
Ferdinand was about 10 years of age and he
was taken into the royal
court is a page boy.
Ferdinand's was a page to
Queen Leonor wife of King John.
The seconds who reigns from 1481 to
1495 he was then 60 to buy his brother,
King Manuel the first at the
beginning of the 16th century.
Just as far as an end was coming of age.
Portugal was the most nautically
advanced country in Europe.
She had the best build ships and the most
experienced sailors on the high seas.
These advances and allowed the Portuguese
to take the lead and exploring the
African west coast.
However,
the Italian states had already established
land based trade routes to the East
shutting Portugal out of
this lucrative markets.
Portuguese businessmen and explorers
sought ways to develop their own route to
the forest that would bypass the
established land based route.
And so the rush was on to find eight
Seabourn route to the eastern markets.
Portuguese explorer Vasco together made
a huge breakthrough when he sailed down
the African coast and around the Cape of
Good Hope and then to the southern tip
of India.
Over the ensuing decade,
the Portuguese established trade
relations with the Indian kingdoms.
You're in Ferdinand's formative years
exploration and trade opportunities.
They were constant topics of interest
among the Portuguese and ability.
The crown was fully invested in this
and they were prepared to finance
explorations
around 1505 Ferdinand's now in his mid
twenties in listed as a member of a 22
ship escort for Francisco Down Meda,
the first viceroy of Portuguese India.
It is also probable that he traveled
to such places like Malaysia and the
African territory of Mozambique.
In the midst of this flourishing
and to cultural trait,
he would have been exposed to a dizzying
array of cultures, languages, foods,
and trade goods.
Magellan.
He remained in employ of the
Portuguese navy for eight years.
He was involved in a number of battles.
The first being the battle of
Canon or in 1506 in this encounter,
the Portuguese fleets of less than 10
shifts to feed it in excess of more than
200 much smaller Indian vessels.
Magellan,
though he was wounded in
this encounter in February,
1509 [inaudible] participated
in the battle of day you
against the Ottoman Turks
and southwestern India, which was
another Portuguese victory. Yeah.
Later he was president when the Indian
city of Goa was overrun having negated
the Muslim push into Asia.
The Portuguese turned their attention
to Malaysia and the city of Malarkey.
This island city.
It was an international port that served
as a gateway to the lucrative spice
markets to the south.
The Portuguese wanted control over the
city and they sent an invasion force to
achieve that.
In 1511 Magellan,
he was one of the invaders
who soon conquered the island.
Towards the end of 1511 Magellan was
awarded for his services with an award of
Richards from an exploratory mission
to the spice islands of Indonesia.
He was also given them ballet
slave who he named Henri k.
This man was to act as a
translator on Magellan's.
Later voyage to the Indian Ocean Magellan.
He returns to Portugal in 1513 he'd spent
eight years on the seas of the indies.
He was out into to a country that was
deeply involved both militarily and
commercially in the African continent
conflicts where I'm going with both the
North African pirates and the
Muslims who inhabited the consonants.
Surely after returning to portrait goal,
Magellan joins an expedition against a
revolt in the Moroccan city of ours or
more. We're okay. I'd been a possession
of the Portuguese since 1486 as a result,
each of its cities were obligated
to pay an annual tribute. However,
in 1513 the ruler of Azamara man by the
name of Mou lays him on refuse to pay.
He then led a revolt against
the Portuguese with the
goal of pushing the invader
out of his country.
The king determined to put down the
rebellion with overwhelming force in order
to teach his subjects the lesson.
He sends an army of 15,000 men under the
leadership of the Duke of brick ends up
this false. It's soon quashed the
uprising within a few years. However,
the Portuguese found that the costs
involved in keeping us more in order,
well more than the revenue generated
from the city and it was abandoned during
the battle of as in more Magellan,
he was thrown from his horse receiving
a leg wound that would leave him with a
limp for the remainder of his life.
This was not the only all happy experience
that he had in Morocco as a prominent
member of the Victoria saw me. He was
awarded some of the spoils of victory,
but before long he was accused of
carrying on illegal trade with locals by
selling some of those spoils back to the
Moroccans that a profit, the accusation.
It was thoroughly investigated
by Magellan's military
superiors and he was found
not guilty. Still the episode. It
certainly left a stain on his sofa.
Exemplary record.
It seems to have lost him considerable
favor with the king whose sister he had
served as a page boy in his
youth on his returned to Lisbon.
Magellan requested an increase in his
pension on the strength of a service in
Morocco,
but this was denied by the king.
When you requested permission to
accompany several Portuguese military
expeditions Magellan,
he was again turned down.
It was pretty apparent to him that
he had lost the trust of demonic
with the king leaving him out in the cold
and Magellan now set about formulating
plans for his own voyage of expiration.
His intention was to find a faster route
to the spice islands by sailing west
across the Atlantic Ocean.
He was unaware of the size of the
Pacific Ocean or the length of the South
American continent sins,
so imagine that this would be quicker
and easier than sailing all the way down
to the southern tip of Africa
to get to the Indian Ocean.
Magellan took his plan to the king
requesting financing for the expedition.
He used the fact that the Spanish were
likely to reach the space islands before
women's claimed jurisdiction
over its valuable space.
Straight as a bit of leverage,
however, it King Manuel,
he was not moved and he turned down
Magellan's request. He did, however,
give permission to seek
funding from other rulers.
Magellan's had his sights on the Spanish
crown is the backer for his expedition.
He traveled to Seville where he met
up with other Portuguese mariners and
navigators. Together they formed a
plan to take to the Spanish crown.
The expedition would be presented as
the opportunity to achieve the Westwood
route to the indies that Columbus had
failed to achieve in the 1490s there's new
routes.
It would also avoid competition with the
Portuguese who were committed to their
well established but much longer route
through the Indian Ocean as icing on the
cake. Magellan contented that's on the
basis of his cartography calculations.
The spice islands would be found a
lie within territory that was in the
possession of the Spanish.
The proposal,
it was attractive to the
Spanish King Charles,
the first Magellan and his cartographer
refill the Arrow when they joined
captains of the expedition.
They were also made knights of the
order of Santiago and given a 10 year
monopoly on all trade in the
area through their route,
along with 5% of all revenues
received from the root. As a bonus,
they would each be given a
governorship on the islands.
The Spanish crown puts up the money
for the purchase of ships and crew and
supplies. This, it was a stunning
success for Magellan. Yup.
Despite the financing and
prospects conferred by the king,
he soon ran into difficulties.
Spanish sailors were incense.
The two Portuguese Marin has had been
placed at the head of the expedition.
When they heard of all the lucrative
benefits that the two would receive,
they were angry is still
members of the Spanish course.
I'm able to stomach the king's generosity
to these foreigners that attempt to do
subvert the expedition.
They're leasing a funds was held
up resulting in a flow on effect,
so that made it virtually impossible
for the two captains to make the
preparations.
Meanwhile,
King Manuel the first back in Portugal
heard about the Spanish financing of the
voyage.
This apparently caused him to feel regret
that he had turned down the request.
By Magellan.
He sat about trying to sabotage the
Spanish expedition as well as sending an
envoy to the Spanish court
for that express purpose.
Brahms developed two between
Magellan and Fatty Arrow.
In fact of the relationship between the
became so strained that finally Arrow
who has his captaincy revoked Indeed's,
he was totally kicked off the expedition.
More personnel problems followed.
The Spanish prevented Magellan
for bringing Portuguese
sailors on board despite
the fact that many of the
men that Magellan wanted
were experienced in sailing
the parts of the ocean that he was headed
to in the ends of the majority of the
group were Spanish,
showed that there was representation
from a number of other lands including
North Africa. Magellan's slave on
Rico also sailed with his master.
Finally,
Magellan had five ships ready to sail.
These were the Tryna Dan's upon which
he sailed the Victoria, the Concepcion,
the Santo, Antonio, and the Santiago.
In total there were 273 men.
Everything we know about Magellan's voyage
comes from the journal that was kept
by a crew member by the name
of Antonio. Bigger, fatter.
They sailed out of Seville
harbor on Saint Lawrence Day,
August the 10th 1519
during his time in Seville,
Magellan had met and married a teenage
girl by the name of Beatrice Barbosa,
who was the daughter of a Portuguese
friends not long thereafter,
Beatrice gave birth to their first
and only child, a son named Rodrigo.
When he sailed out of Seville. This was
the last time he would ever see them.
The fleet sailed down the
Guadalquivir river. Finally,
on September the 20th they headed
out into the Atlantic Ocean.
The first stop was tenor
reef in the Canary Islands.
Getting there was plain sailing,
but the next leg of the journey from tenor
reef southwest across the equator was
beset by wild storms.
The chronic color picker fatter describes
many occasions when the men thought
that they were done for us.
Terrible storm winds battered the ship.
He puts that deliverance down to the
divine inheritance of Saint Anselm who
showed his presence by a
light at the tip of the mast.
What he was actually saying was sent
Alamos fire and electrical charge that is
often seen on the top of
mosques and thunderstorms.
Having navigated the stormy seas
Magellan's set the course for Brazil,
which was a possession of the Portuguese,
but they have not yet established any
substantial settlements that Magellan's
five ships reached the Brazilian coast
in early November and then move south
until they reached the Bay of Rio de
Janeiro. Upon reaching South American,
Magellan had to face the reality of the
geography that it only previously guest
apps.
He had assured the Spanish king this.
He would discover a street through this
consonants that would allow them to pass
into the south seas and then make
a direct runs the east indies.
What he found was that the South American
coast ran for far longer than it ever
imagines and there was no promise that
it finds a straight to cut through it.
The realization that they might be forced
to add an unknown length of time to
their journey by circumnavigating South
America caused to tension among the crew
from Rio de Janeiro.
The fleet traveled south to the Rio de
la Plata estuary that they stopped to
allow the men to explore in Edmond.
Yeah.
They came across a tribe
of natives described by pig
of Fetzer is cannibalistic
giants.
According to his journal accounts,
the crew managed to coax four of the
natives, a board, one of the ships,
while distracting them with
trinkets pickup at a rights.
The captain had the fetters put on the
feet of both of them and when they saw
the bolts across the fat as being struck
with a hammer to reverse and prevent
them from being opens.
These giants were afraid,
but the captain made signs to them
that they should suspect nothing.
Nevertheless perceiving the trick.
This had been played on them.
They began to blow and foam at the mouth
like bulls loudly calling their devil
to help them.
Magellan put the other two in irons,
but then decided to release them.
The actions of the sailors appear
excessively aggressive towards the native
people. Rio De la Plata, this sled
it to devolve into outright combat.
Magellan lost his first man.
When a sailor was hit in the torso
by a poisoned Arrow Magellan.
He made a speedy access, but rather
than head back out to the open seas,
it was decided to head into the river
in the belief that it could just be the
street that would allow them to cross
the continent. It didn't take them long.
However,
to realize that the waters,
they were traveling in fresh water and
so could not have come from the ocean on
the other side of the continent.
When Magellan realized his mistake,
he turned south coming to the port of
San Julian in Argentina just prior to
Easter of 1520 he decided to
they up there over the winter.
The rest who would not be
without incidence I mutiny
was incited by two Spanish.
Captain would resented serving under
a Portuguese man from the stars.
Magellan had the loyalty of the
majority of the men and the dissenters.
They were sidelined and dismissed during
the layer over the Santiago headed off
on a reconnaissance mission to the south.
It became shipwrecked
in the Santa Cruz River.
The ship was lost along with
one of the crew members. Now,
just before we continue
with Magellan's journey,
let me take a moment to tell you about
Squarespace who make these longer videos
possible. Squarespace and powers, and
that's the word they use in their copy,
but I rather like it empowers dreams
and makers and do is it gives them the
tools. Do you bring that creative ideas
to life? Squarespace makes it easy to,
they have this all in one platform
so you can claim your domain,
you can build your website and then you
can even do things like sell on line.
There's no fussing around with,
you know,
getting a domain for one
side and then working hours.
How's it ported over to the other websites
and then working out if you want to,
how to sell something on the internets.
Squarespace make this all very
neat and tidy. It's all very nice.
Plus it's not going to
look too shabby either.
And by that I mean it's going
to look great. They've got
award winning templates,
which are an amazing starting point.
You basically start with a template
and then you know, tweak it,
customize it a bit, make it until
it looks just how yeah wanted.
Plus they've got 24 seven customer
support via chat or email and they've also
got loads of accessible,
not confusing documentation
on how to make your website.
Plus there's email marketing built in
so you can reach your fans and your
customers. Look Squarespace, they
make it easy, so get that domain,
get that site built,
get a shot up and running.
If you want to just had discreet
space.com for a free trial and when you're
ready to launch,
go to squarespace.com forward slash
bio graphics to save 10% off your first
purchase of a website or domain.
Let's get back to Magellan.
Magellan was now down to
four ships out to pick it up.
The crew from the Santiago,
they carried on down the South
American coast to Cape Verdean.
As there they found a straight between
the consonants or mainland's and the
islands of Tierra del Fuego.
It was the straits.
They were looking forward to take them
across the far Roshan and his would come
to be known as the Straits of Magellan.
One ship was sent forth to see whether
the salt water would turn to fresh water
as they progress through the straits.
It didn't and it's the entire fleet.
They had it inland's before long.
They came to a fork in the waters.
Magellan sent the Concepcion and the
Santo Antonio were along the southeast
channel. While his ship, the Trinidads
in the Victoria, they headed south west.
During this exploration,
many of the crew of the sound to Antonio
mutinied since the ship headed back for
Spain,
the remaining three ships,
they figured that the Westwood Channel
was the one to follow and so they headed
down,
it's on November the 30th 1529 by
December the first they had made it to the
South Sea witch Magenta and rechristened
the Pacific Ocean getting through the
streets. It was an impressive
feat of maritime skill with
many treacherous areas.
Haven't been navigators,
Mama gentlemen was ecstatic to have
found the passage had been seeking.
He was also very aware that he was
running desperately low on supplies.
Stopping to forage on
the coast was an option,
but this brought with it the risk of
further conflicts with the native people.
As a result of the decision was made
to push on directly into the ocean.
Despite the lack of food,
they had no idea what they were in for.
It would be another 12 weeks
before land would be cited.
The food situation soon became desperate
with pig [inaudible] are recording.
We only eight older biscuit reduced to
powder and full of grubs and we drank
water that had turned to yellow and
smelled when even the biscuits were gone.
They caught and date wraps and then
they were reduced to chewing on leather
cloth and Sawdust scoby.
It became rampant since the death toll
began to mount among the first to die
with the two giants who had been
captured a few months earlier,
at least 30 of the crew followed them.
Finally in January of 1521 and group
of uninhabited small islands were
scientists finding no food there.
They push it on until they came to the
island of Guam at the beginning of March
on this inhabited islands, they finally
found food and supplies from Guam,
the fleet headed southwest
of the Marianas Islands,
which we know today as the Philippines.
Magellan was keen to establish friendly
relationships with the native people
that thanks to the age of
his translator on Rica.
He was able to establish diplomatic
relations through the giving of gifts,
the demonstration of arms
and tours of his ships,
the people of the Masala islands
on which the fees had lands.
It encouraged them to move on to what
appeared to be the Capitol Island of Subu.
This they did, but I'm sure if
the reception they would receive,
Magellan ordered the artillery to
be fired as they enter the port.
This period unnecessary as the people,
they were friendly but and formed the
opinion that the chief of the island's
Rasha whom Oban was the king
of oldest surrounding islands.
So in securing this friendship,
he imagines that he now had the
allegiance of all of the other islands.
In this though he was mistaken.
Each islands operated as
an independent sovereignty.
Still Magellan headed for the islands
of Makaton believing this here too.
He would get a positive welcome.
However,
the chief of maketime not lap who refuse
to submit to the strange foreigners
Magellan was offended and
withdrew back to Sebu VA.
He prepared his men to attack
the inhabitants possibly
on the intelligence if
Rhonda,
whom I bond.
He was convinced that he
would not encounter a launch
force of resistance. He,
while he was wrong,
when Magellan,
it is false of 60 men waited
to show her on Makaton.
They were confronted by between one
thousand five hundred and three thousand
warriors armed with and Arrows,
the seders at the benefits of Muskets,
but these were cumbersome, slow to load
and unreliable hoping to cause confusion.
Magellan's sent some of his men to burn
the hearts of the natives. However,
they were intercepted and killed
Magellan's attacking forces.
They were unable to gain any grounds.
Being forced to fight from the
short according to pick a fatter.
The natives focus their
attention on Magellan,
the man who was the
leader of the invaders,
he describes the end
of his captain as such.
So many of them challenge down on us
that they shut the captain through the
right leg with a poison dairy and that's
a county ordinance to retire slowly.
But the men took the flight except six
to eight of us who remained with the
captain.
The natives,
Sean Tony has our legs for the latter
were bad and so many where the spears and
stones that they held at us that
we could offer no resistance.
The natives continue to pursue us and
picking up the same spare four or six
times,
held it at us again and again recognizing
the captain and so many tons upon him
that they knocked his
helmet on his head twice,
but he always stood firmly like a good
night and Indian held a bamboo spear into
the captains face,
but the latter immediately killed him
with a lunch which she left and the
Indians body then drying to lay
hand on sword. He could draw it out,
but halfway because he had been wounded
in the arm with a bamboo spirit.
When the native saw that they
all held themselves as upon him,
one of them wounded him in the left
leg with a large cutlass that calls the
captain to full face downward when they
immediately rushed upon him with iron
and bamboo spears and with their
cutlasses until they killed off mirror our
light, our compass, and our true
guide. When they wounded him,
he turns back many times to see whether
we were all in the boats therap on
holding him dead.
We wounded retreated as best we could
to the boats which were already pulling
off the ship,
made a speedy departure to Sebago need
to find that Roger Hemovon was no longer
friendly. He had around 30 of the sailors
poisoned during a feast. After that,
the surviving set sail
for the spice islands.
The goal of reaching those islands
when it was finally mess bus Magellan,
his page,
the ultimate price in its achievements,
more than 90% of his men had
also perished on the voyage.
The captains of the two remaining ships
disagreed about the re time. As a result,
they parted ways with the Trinidad
sailing back across the Pacific while the
Victoria took the Portuguese rouge
around the Cape of Good Hope.
As it turned out to the Trinidad was
stopped by Portuguese officials with its
crew being arrested.
Victoria arrived back in Seville,
Spain on September the sixth 1522
the ship was and down with spices,
but the crew were near death
from starvation and the ship,
but it was about to fall apart.
Only 18 men were on board from a total
of 237 who had set sail from that port
three years out of the APP.
But those 18 men,
while they had the distinction of being
the first to second navigate the globe.
So I really hope you found this
video interesting. If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button
as a ways and also subscribe.
Why nots Squarespace as well? Check
these guys out. There's a link below,
and as always,
thank you for watching.